welcome back now let's do a problem that
involves almost everything we've learned
so far about probability and
combinations and conditional probability
so let's say I have a bag again and in
that bag I have five fair coins five
fair and I have ten unfair coins ten
unfair and a fair coin of course there's
a 50/50 chance of getting heads or tails
and the unfair coin let's say that there
is a 80% chance of getting a heads for
any one of those coins and that there is
a 20% chance of getting tails right
because it's going to either be heads or
tails so my question is is I what
happens is I put my hand in the bag and
I my eyes are closed and I picked out a
coin and then I flip it six times and it
turns out that I got five out of well
let's say yeah well no let me do it
let's say I got four out of six heads
that's the result I got what I want to
know is what is the probability that I
picked out a fair coin given that I got
four out of six heads so before moving
on let's do a little bit of review of
Bayes theorem and I think that'll give
us a good framework for the rest of this
problem so Bayes theorem let me let me
do it in this corner up here Bayes
theorem tells us the probability of both
a and B happening that upside down U is
just intersection and set theory but
it's essentially saying you know it's
the set of events in which both a and B
occur that's equal to the probability of
a occurring given B times the
probability of B which is also equal to
the probability of B occurring given a
time's the probability okay I think this
should make some intuition to you for
you if it doesn't it might be a good
idea to watch the the conditional
probability videos but what we can do is
we can rearrange this equation right
here to get if we just divide both sides
by the probability of B we get the
probability and I'll do this in a
vibrant color the probability of a given
B is equal to the probability of B given
a time's the probability of a divided by
the probability of B I just took this
equation divided both sides by the
probability of B and I got this so what
is a and B in the problem we're trying
to figure out we want to try to figure
out the probability that I picked out a
fair coin given that I got four out of
six heads so in this situation a is that
I got a fair coin a is equal to picked
fair coin picked fair and then B is V is
equal to four out of six heads four out
of six cents so in order to figure out
the probability that I picked a fair
coin given that I got four six adds I
have to know the probability of getting
four out of six heads given a fair that
I picked the fair coin times the
probability of picking out a fair coin
divided by the probably getting four out
of six heads in general so this is
probably the hardest part to figure out
and we will along the way will actually
probably figure out the top two terms so
what's the probability of B or the
probability of getting four out of six
heads let's see what happens right when
I I put my hand into the bag and I pick
out a coin there is a five and ten
chance or in five and fifteen chance
right there fifteen total coins that I
pick a fair coin so five and fifteen
that's the same thing as 1/3 that I pick
a fair coin and then there is a
two-thirds chance that I pick a unfair
coin right now if I pick a fair coin
given I that I have a fair coin what is
the probability what is the probability
given the fair coin what is the
probability that I get four out of six
heads well once again let's think about
the previous several videos what's the
probability giving any one particular
combination of four out of six heads so
for example you know it could be heads
tails heads tails heads heads it could
be I don't know it could be the first
four heads heads heads heads heads tails
tails right and there are a bunch of
these and we once again will use the the
binomial coefficient or we'll use our
knowledge of combinations to figure out
how many different combinations there
are but what's the probability of each
of these combinations
well what's probability of heads that's
0.5 times 0.5 times 0.5 times 0.5 and
then the probability of tails this is a
fair coin is also point 5 times 0.5
times 0.5 so each of these there's a 1/2
chance of getting a heads times 1/2
chance of a tail some someone's 1/2
chance of a heads times 1/2 chance of a
tail 6 etc so each of these are
essentially you know 1/2 times 1/2 6
times so the probability of each of the
combinations is 1/2 to the 6th power 1/2
to the 6th power and so how many
combinations are there like this where
you get out of the 6 flips you're
choosing you're essentially choosing 4
heads you're choosing you know if I'm
once again the god of probability I am
picking for exactly four of the six
heads sorry I'm picking four of exactly
six of the flips to end up heads right
I'm choosing which of the the flips get
you know selected so to speak so it's
essentially there are going to be out of
out of six flips I'm choosing as a god
of probability for to be heads so that's
the number of combinations
I've cut the number of unique
combinations where you have four out of
six heads times the probability of each
of the combinations which is 1/2 to the
sixth power
well what's 6 choose 4 that's sick
factorial over 4 factorial times 6 minus
4 factorial so that's 2 factorial and
that's times 1/2 to the sixth and I'll
switch colors again just to stop the
monotony and that equals see 6 times 5
times 4 times 3 times 2 we don't have to
write the wrong times 1 I'll do it
anyway over 4 factorial 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 and then 2 factorial 2 times 1
so that cancels with that the 1 we can
ignore to 2 divide both sides by the
numerator and denominator by 2 and this
becomes 2/3 so this becomes 15 so this
equals 15 times 1/2 to the 6 what's 1/2
to 6 that's 1 over 64 right so 1 over 64
so becomes 15 over 64 so the probability
of getting four out of six heads given a
fair coin is 15 out of 64 so this is the
probability of four out of six heads
given a fair coin and if you look at it
based on our definition of B and a this
is the probability of B given a right B
is four out of six heads given a fair
coin fair enough
so let's figure out the probability of
because there's two ways of getting four
out of six heads one that we picked a
fair coin and then you know times 15 out
of 64 and then there's a probability
that we picked an unfair coin so what's
the probability of the unfair coin of
getting of getting four out of six heads
given the unfair coin well once again
what's probably if each of the
combinations we get four out of six so
in this situation let's do the same one
heads tails heads tails heads heads
right that's four out of six heads but
in this situation it's not a 50% chance
of getting heads 80% so it would be 0.8
times 0.2 times 0.8 times 0.2 times 0.8
times 0.8 is essentially we have you
know this multiplication we can
rearrange it because it doesn't matter
what order you multiply things in so
it's point eight to the fourth power
times 0.2 squared right it's it and it
doesn't matter you know any any of the
unique combinations will each have the
same probability because we can just
rearrange the the order in which we
multiply right and then how many of
these combinations are there if we are
once again the god of probability and
out of six flips we are picking four
we're choosing four that are going to
end up heads how many ways can I pick a
group of four well once again that's
times 6 choose 4 and we figured out what
that is 6 choose 4 is 15 so this equals
15 15 times 0.8 to the fourth times 0.2
squared so the probability so the end
this so this is this is the probability
of four out of four out of six heads
given an unfair coin so what's the total
probability of getting four out of six
heads well it's going to be the
probability of getting the fair coin
which is one-third times the probability
giving four out of six heads given the
fair coin and that's this 15 over 64
times 15 over 64 plus the probability of
an unfair coin two-thirds times the
probability of getting four out of six
heads given the unfair coin and that's
what we figured out here times 15 times
0.8 to the fourth 2 times 0.2 squared
and this is the probability of getting
four out of six heads and let's figure
out what that is well this is one of
this is just this will cancel out with
this it becomes five out of 64 that's
easy enough two-thirds times fifteen
that's ten and now we just have to
figure out what that is let's see I'm
gonna go over the time limit to see if
being a YouTube Partner allows me to go
over the time limit
see point 8 times 0.8 times 0.8 times
0.8 is equal to and then times 0.2
squared so times 0.2 times 0.2 is equal
to 0.01 6 so that's that and then we say
times 10 right because 2/3 times 15 so
times 10 is equal to sixteen point three
eight four percent so the probability is
so this term right here let me write
that down and I'll switch colors again
this is 0.16 three eight four and we're
going to add that to five divided by 64
so let's see five divided by 64 is equal
to 0.074 whatever plus 0.16
three eight four is equal to 0.2 four
one nine six five so that's the
probability not knowing which coin I
picked out that's the probability of
getting four out of six heads when you
when you combine it you know it could be
one-third chance fair two-thirds chance
unfair so that's 24 point one nine
I'm keeping the precision just because
it might come in useful later percent
chance so that's the probability of B so
let's see if we can clean this up a
little bit just because I don't think we
need all of this writing now I think
we're ready to substitute into the our
Bayes formula which we base theorem that
we read arrived let me derive no but
that's not what I wanted to do according
longer videos is dangerous because if I
make a mistake that's more time wasted I
don't want to delete anything that could
be useful okay so let's see if we can
solve the probability that we picked a
fair coin given that we got four out of
six heads so that is going to be equal
to by Bayes theorem which should make
some sense to you that is
is equal to the probability of B given a
so it's the probability that we get four
out of six heads given a fair coin times
the probability of a fair coin over the
probability of getting four out of six
heads either way 406 heads so four out
of six heads given a fair coin we
figured that over here that's 15 over 64
so this equals 15 over 64 what's the
probability that we picked a fair coin
well there's 15 coins and five of them
were fair so it's 5 out of 15 so it's
1/3 sometimes one-third and what's the
probability that in general we picked
four out of six heads well that's that's
this number 0.2 four one nine six five
so this equals let's see this is equal
to five over 64 divided by 0.2 four one
nine six five and what is that equal to
that's five divided by 64 it's equal to
that divided by 0.2 four one nine six
five is equal to 32 point well roughly
three percent is equal to 32 point three
percent so that's amazing or relatively
amazing weave now it's a little bit less
than a one-third shot that we picked the
fair coin given that we got four out of
six heads oh and and and what's
interesting is the four out of six heads
it kind of decreased the probability
that we got a fair coin right because if
the before having any data on on what
happens when we flip it we would have
had a one-third probability which is
thirty-three point three right but given
that we got more heads than tails kind
of the universe of probability is is
telling us that well if you got more
heads than tails that makes it a little
bit more likely that you picked the
unfair coin which is a little bit more
weighted to heads but saying it's not
that much more likely because this isn't
that unusual of a result to get even
with a fair coin and so that's why it
became a little bit
likely to get a fair coin I will
actually land let me give you a let me
give you a bit of an intuition visually
kind of what set theory on why that
makes sense why that makes sense so if
we go back to Bayes theorem let's just
say that you know this is our let me
this is the universe of all of the
events right that's all of the universe
there's roughly a one-third chance that
I picked a fair coin so roughly
one-third of this will be fair this is
fair this is unfair right and then if I
picked a fair coin we figured out that
it's roughly a fifteen out of 64 shot
that I get I get four out of six heads
so maybe that's this little section of
the let me do it in a different color
that's this section and then we figured
out if we have an unfair coin I forgot
what the exact number is but there was
some probability that we get four out of
six heads right it's actually a little
bit bigger it's like that right so this
is getting four out of six heads given
you got an unfair coin this is getting
four out of six heads given that you got
a fair coin and then this whole area is
a probability to get four out of six
heads
so all Bayes theorem told us is look we
got four out of six heads so this this
where in this universe where we got four
out of six heads and if we got four out
of six heads one-third of this universe
roughly you're thirty two point three
percent of this subset of four out of
six heads intersects with the fair coin
universe right so this 32.3% is
essentially this fraction of the total
probability of getting four out of six
heads anyway hopefully that gave you a
little bit of intuition and I hope that
YouTube lets me publish this video
because I'm on my 17th minute I'll see
you in the next video